Brian believes the skull on the left is
not human I doubt that that the
ancestors of these people are what we
call Homo sapiens in the past my nephew
and I did a water displacement
experiment to test Brian's claim that
the baracus skulls are 25% larger than
human skulls it turned out that Brian
was wrong at least he was wrong about
the skulls we measured Jackson and I
were only able to measure casts not the
original thing but locals in Peru
directly measured the inside of the
largest skull in their Museum they also
found like we did that even though these
skulls are longer than normal they're
also narrower the size of their brain is
human but what about their eye sockets
and other claims Brian has made if you
click the play button near the title
below or look in the video description
you'll find the full video where I using
the exact skull replica Brian tells
people to buy in his book test each of
his claims about the elongated skulls of
Peru